- Hi I'm Sal Khan, founder
of the Khan Academy,
and I just wanted to let you know about
our India Talent Search.
As you might know Khan
Academy we're a not for profit
with a mission of providing
a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere.
And to us it means that if
you are a villager someplace
and you don't have access
to a formal school,
that you might be able to
access a low cost smartphone
and then be able to self-educate yourself
and one day prove what
you know so that you could
get a job or go and get
into higher education.
But ideally you're using Khan Academy
in conjunction with a classroom.
Where the classroom can
allow students to learn
and work at their own pace,
give data to teachers,
free up class time for open-ended projects
or peer-to-peer learning
or Socratic dialogue.
And so we have a call out for the talent,
the teaching talent in India,
to work with us.
By being part of this talent search,
one, you'll get a chance to
practice making videos yourself.
And we're looking for folks
in math and science initially,
but eventually all subjects.
But it's a way for us to find talent,
talent that can help us create content
that will educate tens
of millions of learners
throughout India.
So the opportunity here is
I think pretty exciting.
There will be prizes, but
maybe the biggest prize of all
is the opportunity to
contribute and to help
your fellow citizens.
And now I'm gonna hand it off to Aanand.
who is our head of content in India.
- I'm really very excited to invite you
to Khan Academy India's
second talent search.
We've been looking for teachers
to help us reach our mission
of creating content that's
relevant to the Indian learners.
Now one big piece of
this is to map a content
to the Indian syllabus,
which means the content that you create
will be used directly by
teachers and students,
millions of them, to help their
school experience directly.
Now another big piece of
what we wanna do for India
is to make Khan Academy's
content available
in all major Indian languages.
Now we already have Khan
Academy available in a few
Indian languages, but
we really wanna take it
to the next step over here.
Now to achieve both of these,
in my opinion, the most
important thing is to find
the right content creators.
Not just creators who are
passionate about their subjects,
but also creators who
are really passionate
about making education available
to millions of learners.
And that's the primary
purpose of this talent search.
We are looking for
science and math teachers
and content creators in five languages,
English and Hindi, but also Kannada,
Tamil and Marathi.
And we're looking to give out 10 winners,
give out prizes for 10 winners,
one winner and one runner's up in each of
these five languages.
So if you are a creator
or if you know a creator,
make sure you spread the word
and help as many people know
about this talent search
and help us find the
right content creators
to get closer to our mission.
The last date for sending
your entries is December 17.
And now I'm happy to introduce
two of last year's winners
who now work with us, Mahesh and Ram,
to say a little bit about their experience
with Khan Academy.
- Hi my name is Mahesh Shenoy.
I was the winner of the last
year's India Talent Search,
and now the newest and a proud member
of Khan Academy Team India.
Over the past two and a half years,
I've been making YouTube physics videos,
and so I've learned a great
deal about video creation.
However, two days with this team,
and I realized I have
so much more to learn.
We are a small team of passionate people
but with a huge mission,
a mission to educate tens of millions
of young lives of India.
And if you feel you too
have the same passion,
here's an opportunity to join us.
- Hi, I'm Ram, one of last
year's Talent Search winners.
I love physics, and I've been
teaching it for a long time.
What I'm excited about
is that now I can help
millions of kids in the
country love physics
the way I do.
And since the entire content is free,
that means even the kids
who do not have a shot
at quality education can
now educate themselves
using my videos.
So if you want to help us
in achieving our mission,
please do send us your videos.
And trust me, video creation
process is a lot simpler
and more fun than it seems like.
- Now when we evaluate your videos,
we will look a lot more
at their content depth
and explanation rather than fancy visuals
or production value,
so make sure that or rather don't hesitate
to just point a camera at
a piece of paper or a board
as you explain your idea.
Remember that the last
date is December 17,
and make sure you spread the word.